In 2018, chances are that everyone has multiple
favorite Netflix movies and TV shows.
And it's also a safe bet that everyone is
super excited for upcoming Netflix originals
that are arriving on a wave of hype.
But with so much new content added to the
streamer every day, it's impossible to keep
track of everything.
Thus, some future movies and shows have fallen
under the radar even though they actually
feature big stars and buzzworthy premises.
Let's take a closer look at upcoming Netflix
originals that nobody is talking about…yet.
The Chilling Adventures of Sabrina
Riverdale executive producer Roberto Aguirre-Sacasa
is bringing Sabrina the Teenage Witch to Netflix,
although she won't be anything like Melissa
Joan Hart's version.
This version is based on the comic series
Chilling Adventures of Sabrina, which tells
a dark origin story for the witchy teen.
The show follows Sabrina, played by Mad Men's
Kiernan Shipka, as she tries to balance being
half-witch and half-mortal while fighting
against evil forces.
Chilling Adventures already has a two-season,
20-episode order, so expect quite a lot of
magical mishaps in Greendale after it premieres
on October 26th.
And, hopefully, a Riverdale crossover or two.
Russian Doll
Natasha Lyonne has already had success with
a Netflix hit, earning an Emmy nomination
for her work on Orange is the New Black.
She's set to team up with the streamer once
again for Russian Doll, which she co-created
with Amy Poehler and Sleeping With Other People
director Leslye Headland.
The eight-episode series stars Lyonne as a
young woman named Nadia who, throughout one
endless night, serves as the guest of honor
at a "seemingly inescapable party."
The show has been described as "an ambitious
and uniquely formatted comedy that will have
viewers guessing as much as they will be laughing."
With that description and the incredibly talented
cast, this is shaping up to be one of your
new favorite shows.
The Eddy
La La Land director Damien Chazelle is getting
back into the musical game.
The Oscar winner is set to executive produce
and direct two episodes of the musical drama
series The Eddy, which is set in modern-day,
multicultural Paris.
It will revolve around a jazz club with American
and French-Arab co-owners.
The show will tell the story of "a club, its
owner, the house band, and the chaotic city
that surrounds them."
The Eddy will be shot in France with dialogue
in French, English, and Arabic.
The eight-episode series also has BAFTA Award-winning
writer Jack Thorne on board, as well as Grammy
Award-winning composer Glen Ballard writing
the original score.
Dolly Parton anthology
Dolly Parton is one of the greatest songwriters
who's ever lived.
She's had a hand in penning almost all of
her most memorable hits, including "I Will
Always Love You," "9 to 5," "Coat of Many
Colors," and "Jolene."
She has a knack for composing songs that feel
like real people are singing about real situations,
and Netflix is going to turn some of those
into narrative films.
In 2018, the service announced plans for an
eight-part anthology series, in which each
episode will be a self-contained story based
on one of Parton's tunes.
In a press statement, the singer said,
"We hope our show will inspire and entertain
families and folks of all generations."
Parton will executive produce the series as
well as briefly appear in a few episodes.
Sunshine Scouts
After more than a decade creating hit shows
for ABC, television juggernaut Shonda Rhimes
signed a deal in April 2018 to bring her "Shondaland"
brand to Netflix.
Three months later, the prolific Rhimes announced
that she and her crew were at work on a whopping
eight different series, including dramas,
documentaries, and even a pitch black half-hour
comedy called Sunshine Scouts.
Overseen by Rhimes but created by writer/actress
Jill Alexander, the series takes place after
an event of apocalyptic proportions destroys
a great deal of civilization and life on Earth.
A group of teenage girl scouts at a summer
camp have to band together to thrive in this
brave new world.
They abide by "Sunshine Scout Law" and use
their many scouting skills to find food and
shelter and avoid nuclear fallout.
Norm Macdonald Has a Show
Finally, Norm Macdonald, arguably the greatest
talk show guest ever, will host his own talk
show.
The one-of-a-kind comedian will soon be inviting
guests to talk to and mock, as Norm Macdonald
Has a Show premieres September 14th.
Following David Letterman, Chelsea Handler,
and Michelle Wolf, Macdonald joins the Netflix
lineup of late-night talk shows you can watch
anytime.
He'll be a co-showrunner in addition to hosting,
and his sidekick will be Adam Eget, his co-host
on the Norm Macdonald Live podcast.
The initial guest lineup includes Drew Barrymore,
David Spade, Judge Judy, David Letterman,
Jane Fonda, Chevy Chase, M. Night Shyamalan,
Michael Keaton, Billy Joe Shaver, and Lorne
Michaels.
Turn Up Charlie
After stepping away from the small screen
for a while to appear in multiple movie franchises,
Idris Elba will return to television with
an edgy comedy called Turn Up Charlie.
He co-created the show, and it's about a topic
close to his heart: electronic music.
Elba's a DJ in real life, and the show is
about an aging bachelor and EDM DJ who agrees
to be a caretaker for his celebrity best friend's
obnoxious young daughter.
Turn Up Charlie should turn up on Netflix
in late 2018 or 2019.